hey guys it's max we just got in the
brand-new 2020 MacBook Air and in this
video we not only are gonna run some
benchmarks to see how well it performs
both in CPU and graphics tests but we're
also gonna be testing out thermal
throttling I know somebody has been
asking about that and that is because
Apple now gives us a four core option in
the new MacBook Air and better graphics
as well now another thing we're gonna
figure out is if the i-5 model which
only costs $100 more than the base model
comes with the same graphics as the base
or does have the faster g7 graphics of
the i7 version which is another $150 and
we're gonna cross our fingers and hope
so because that's gonna make this an
awesome value now one thing that I
already noticed is that it is quite warm
on the bottom of the MacBook Air and all
I've really done is just download my
testing apps which is very interesting I
want to let you guys also know that I
will be doing a direct comparison
against a previous MacBook Air and the
base 13-inch MacBook core that has a
quad core processor so that's gonna be
very interesting make sure you guys are
subscribed with those notifications in
abled let's go ahead and turn on our
Geekbench 5 here ok and the yes haha so
if you guys see right there Intel Core
i5
we have the g7 graphics ok that's a big
sigh of relief because this means that
pretty much everybody could save 150
bucks if this laptop the i5 version has
a quad core but not the best graphics
then it may be worth spending another
150 to get those best graphics
especially if you want to do like video
editing stuff like that but thankfully
yes we have the g7 graphics on this I 5
model that's gonna make this MacBook Air
an even better deal for most of you guys
a hundred bucks more than the base you
get twice the the CPU cores and you get
the better graphics man I I think this
laptops gonna be very popular and I'll
go ahead and link it down in the video
description as well let's go ahead and
start out with the CPU test alright here
are the results so we have a thousand
and ten for single core score and 25 73
for multi-core so that's about a 25%
boost in single core performance and
that brings it up to all the new modern
max even like the Mac Pro for single
core tasks now I'm looking at my kind of
estimations of what the multi-core
performance would be and not to say that
I did overestimate a bit but I want to
take a little bit of a closer look if
we're gonna take a look at temps and
fans because I didn't hear the fan at
all yes this does have a fan in it
before look at that let's go and run a
compute score with that new graphics
I'll hit metal here alright we have our
score here it is eight thousand two
hundred and twenty eight the previous
one here's a six seventeen three
thousand a hundred and forty eight so
more than twice as much nearing three
times the graphics performance that is
really good now mostly to be testing a
gaming benchmark but we will come back
to that later now I want to open up TG
fan pro sorry now we're idling at about
70 degrees Celsius which is on the
warmer side and this is surprising it
says that our fan speeds go up to 8,000
rpm and clearly that hasn't been
happening in these benchmarks so it's
gonna be very interesting to see what
happens
as we start up our Cinebench our xx and
cinnamon chart when he's gonna push all
of these cores to their limits and we're
really gonna see the maximum CPU
performance but also we're gonna stress
it and give it the maximum heat to see
if the fan can keep up now that it's a
four core instead of a dual core so
Intel power gadgets gonna show us
wattage as well and the base frequency
for the CPU is 1.1 gigahertz and goes up
to 3.5 so I'm curious what is it gonna
actually run out when we're pushing it
and will it thermal throttle so 2
gigahertz right here two point seven two
point four two point three but our core
max actually showing higher only 13
Watts right now and that is not high at
all so we are not having a you series
processor that could go up to say 25
watts so this is definitely a 4 chord
that is meant for energy efficiency
number one and if you guys are paying
attention we're running at one point
five seven one point five eight
gigahertz now for all of our cores
running at maximum and
a hundred degrees Celsius that is crazy
99 a hundred so this thing is getting
hot and yes it is thermal throttling it
could run at least 2.4 with all the
cores of course that 3.5 rating is just
with one core if it's cool until it
tries to kind of stretch out those
numbers but now as we're maybe about a
third done we're using about 10 watts
it's trying to keep it cool 100 degrees
Celsius and 1.47 gigahertz that is
pretty slow and as far as the fan speeds
I don't know if I can even hear it and
it says we're actually running at 4000
RPM instead of 8,000 so let's go ahead
and open up our TG fan Pro here yeah
look we're actually running very very
low here maybe about a third and it's
running at a hundred degrees so what the
sixteen inch macbook rope Apple is
really trying to keep that cool the fans
get louder but this thing they're just
trying to lower the power usage to keep
it running not even cool keep it running
a hot so let let me do this okay can you
guys hear that 8,000 rpm that's loud
let's see what happens to our attempts
here
okay so nothing's changed yet it's very
loud but the temps are staying now if
you guys saw some tear downs of the
previous MacBook Air there's a fan in
here but it's not really connected
directly to the heatsink so I'm gonna be
very curious opening up this MacBook Air
and seeing if they change anything and
that will be in my direct comparison to
the previous MacBook Air which we will
have coming out very soon so make sure
your notifications are enabled so it
looks like even though the fans spin
loud we're not getting much benefit here
a very very slight benefit so now it
makes sense why Apple is basically not
kicking up those fans by themselves
allowing it just to run hot because it
doesn't seem like it does that much so
we just finished up here and we got a
score of 863 for the CPU for maxing
every
out now to be honest with you guys and
say that this scenario is not realistic
at all in the real world even if you're
doing things like video editing
especially with programs like Final Cut
where in that case a lot of times your
CP is running between ten percent twenty
maybe fifty sometimes and it's spiking
up and down so it's not like it's a
hundred percent CPU load maxed out and
the newer programs actually focus way
more on graphics which is why I'm so
glad that this MacBook Air has the g7
graphics now when you're doing simple
tasks like say opening up a web browser
right there just hit three point three
gigahertz and that's where you guys see
the heats not really going up here it's
thing right over here it's not getting
super hot and we're getting that power
to do stuff very quickly let's open up
Geekbench five BAM so you guys see we're
getting a spike in power spike in
performance a little spike in heat but
it goes right back down let's do maybe a
little bit of a tougher one over here
will open up Cinebench and as you guys
saw it actually spiked looks like 3.5
gigahertz when you're opening up this
tougher program the only time I really
see the CPU being completely maxed out
consistently is when I'm transcoding
footage say from some regular codec to
ProRes to make it easier to edit but
with this MacBook Air it actually has
the latest decoding chips even better
than my Mac Pro because it's the 10th
generation processors so a lot of those
the footage they even 10 bit hig 65 that
is a special chip that will decode that
and make it easier to video edit so
that's why I'm excited to test out video
editing on this machine as well and see
how it can keep up with that better
graphics card so now let's go ahead and
open up our unit in heaven and we will
do a graphics test so I'm running the
extreme preset here and it looks like
we're running at about seven eight nine
fps sometimes higher the GPU temperature
says it's at 83 degrees Celsius all
right we have our results the FPS is 8.3
that definitely isn't very good now I
don't know how well the other MacBook
Air did I don't think we ever tested it
because it obviously was not meant for
or you know gaming or you know video
editing photo editing that kind of stuff
and now we actually have better graphics
better CPU so this might be able to do
some of that so we will be doing a
direct comparison not only against the
MacBook Air but also against the base
13-inch MacBook Pro I know that laptop
has better cooling than this but this
should have better graphics as well so
it's gonna be interesting seeing some
real-world tests not just some benchmark
so make sure you guys have those
notifications enabled now what is my
overall consensus well yes the MacBook
Air does thermal throttle unfortunately
I guess they probably didn't change the
heatsink inside of here and for regular
tasks it does hit that 3.2 even 3.5
gigahertz and everything is very snappy
with this machine so if you're gonna be
using it for web browsing maybe some
photo editing some lighter video editing
where you're not maxing everything out
constantly you should actually do a
pretty decent job but if you're gonna be
doing something like you're pushing
gaming to the max or you're you know
doing full CPU tasks that max it out all
the time which I don't know how much of
you guys will do that with this machine
let me know down in the comment section
below in that case it might be better to
go for that 13-inch MacBook Pro but
we'll have to see in that comparison
video so thank you guys for watching
click that little circle above to
subscribe and if you guys want to see
some of our other videos we have a
couple great ones right over there this
one max and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]